is forces ramping up ground operations
in the Gaza Strip war between isra and
Hamas threat to exing that aircraft
carrier into the wider
region the war between Israel and Hamas
is escalating as Israeli troops begin
their ground Invasion into the Gaza
Strip comat Advance Gaza but this war
isn't just between these two sides it
actually involves multiple countries and
groups all with different interests and
capabilities and all with the power to
influence this war in this video I want
to show you each of these groups I want
to show you who they are what they want
what their calculations are and to show
you how this war between Israel and
Hamas is threatening to Spread spread to
the rest of the region but also to the
rest of the world and US officials are
worried that this could escalate Beyond
just a conflict between the Israelis and
the Palestinians and could in fact
become a regional War the Gaza Strip is
one of two Palestinian territories it's
home to over over 2 million Palestinians
and it's different than the West Bank
the West Bank is cut up and governed by
a mix of Israeli occupation and a
Palestinian national
government Gaza on the other hand is
governed by Hamas an islamist
organization with a milisha wing whose
mission is to resist and oppose Israel
to fight against Israeli occupation of
Palestinians by whatever means necessary
including terrorism and violence Hamas
chose October 7th 2023 to launch the
most deadly attack breaking down the
border wall surrounding the Gaza Strip
and massacring civilians in a ground and
Rocket assault on
Israel this terrorist attack killed an
estimated 1,400 Israelis and Hamas ended
up taking 229 hostages back to the Gaza
Strip that Hamas is expert at using
tunnels and basement to to hide people
including hostages it was a senseless
Slaughter of innocent lives and it was
the most deadly attack in Israel's
history immediately after the attack
Israel declares war on Hamas they call
up a reservist force of 360,000 soldiers
and they immediately start bombing the
Gaza Strip thousands of air strikes and
Gaza is now cut off from electricity
water and food their stated mission is
not just to strike back against Hamas
but to end the group forever Israel's
Furious strikes on Gaza are laying waste
to entire
[Music]
neighborhoods Israel says that the north
of the Gaza Strip is now an evacuation
Zone that they're going to bomb and they
tell the 1 million Palestinians living
there to leave to evacuate towards the
South but Palestinians can't leave this
area their southern border is with Egypt
and Egypt has vowed that they will not
let anyone in the Prime Minister made
this point very clearly by saying that
Egypt is willing to sacrifice quote
millions of lives to avoid allowing
Palestinians into Egypt so the air
strikes continue and Israel says that
they are preparing for a ground Invasion
to send troops into the Gaza Strip to
Target Hamas Fighters and
leaders this is when Israel's most
important Ally swoops in Joe Biden the
US president has landed in Israel
President Joe Biden travels to Israel
and urges the Israeli Prime Minister to
not make the same mistake that the US
made after 9/11 sending in troops to
wage a grueling and doomed War against
highly motivated Fighters and eventually
ending up fighting in dense cities where
militants and civilians blend
together the US learned that no matter
how powerful your military is this kind
of warfare is brutal and very difficult
to achieve any kind of Victory the US is
also worried that if Israel invades Gaza
that it will trigger a broader conflict
in the Middle East and this is where we
need to zoom out to get a bigger picture
look at the rest of this region war
between Israel and Hamas threatens to
explode into the wider region if we want
to understand the geopolitics of this
region you have to look at Iran Iran is
the country that wants to be the most
powerful and influential country in the
Middle East this puts them in direct
conflict with Israel a powerful country
that is nuclear armed that is also a
foothold for the United States to
project its power in the Middle East in
Iran's
neighborhood so there's this deep enity
between Iran and Israel and by extension
the United States
instead of attacking Israel directly
which would be a catastrophe Iran
opposes Israel by funding a network of
anti-israel and anti-jewish militia
groups and governments around the region
giving them money and weapons as part of
what they call the axis of resistance
against Israel and by extension the
United States one of these groups in the
axis of resistance is Hamas Iran
supports Hamas by giving them training
money and very importantly weapons like
the thousands of rockets that Hamas
fired into Israel on October 7th as a
part of their attack this axis of
resistance exists to keep constant
pressure on Israel to make Israel think
twice about ever attacking Iran Iran
needs Israel to think that this network
is a credible threat that they will act
if Israel does something that they don't
like so as Israel bombards the Gaza
Strip killing all of these civilians
Iran and their axis of resistance feels
pressure to respond so you start to see
all these smallscale attacks all
throughout the region targeting Israeli
and American targets increasing attacks
by Iranian proxies on US forces
stationed in the region most of this
action breaks out in Israel's northern
border with Lebanon home to Iran's most
powerful proxy group called Hezbollah a
political and military organization with
tens of thousands of well-trained
soldiers they're armed to the teeth and
they're funded by Iran they have over a
100,000 missiles of varying ranges
capable of hit hitting almost all of
Israel Hezbollah is actually a much
greater threat to Israel than Hamas is
in Gaza and in the weeks following the
attack Hezbollah shows that they're
ready to fight by shooting at Israeli
military installations along this border
region Israel Strikes Back at Hezbollah
in these border skirmishes threatening
an escalation they drop bombs on two
airports in Syria airports where Iran
sends weapons and supplies to Hezbollah
it looks like an escalation especially
as Israel moves most of its soldiers up
here not to Gaza while tens of thousands
of Israeli citizens are evacuated
attacks by Hezbollah on Israel are
continuing with its Fighters destroying
an Israeli tank the US continues to urge
Israel not to invade Gaza fearing that a
ground Invasion would cross hezbollah's
red line and provoke them to invade from
the north turning this into a two-front
war which could boil over into a three
front War if Palestinians in the West
Bank rise up and start fighting with
Israeli settlers and soldiers who occupy
the West Bank the key to a spread of the
conflict lies on the Israel Lebanon
border if that becomes a second front
the entire region will then feel the
heat one of the paradoxes of global
conflict is that even when all of the
sides don't actually want a fullscale
war they have nothing to gain from it a
fullscale war can break out anyway and
in this case what might not be obvious
is that Hezbollah and Iran actually
don't want a fullscale war with Israel
which would bring a war to Lebanon a
country that has been crumbling under
economic turmoil in recent years for
which some Lebanese blame Hezbollah a
war would deepen this crisis and deepen
the resentment for Hezbollah and
threaten their ability to operate in
Lebanon and yet as Israeli Jets continue
to bombard the Gaza Strip Hezbollah and
their Iranian sponsors have to show that
they are willing to act that they are a
credible threat that they have red lines
that are being crossed this is the
deadly game of chicken that escalates
conflicts like this this is what turns
them into a situation that no one can
control but another Paradox of global
conflict is that some threats of force
can actually diffuse the tension can
stabilize an escalating Conflict at
least that's the bet that the United
States made here the Pentagon too 300
more troops to the mid East while Israel
was still debating whether or not to
send troops into Gaza the US deploys two
Naval Strike groups one off the coast of
Israel and the other off the coast of
Iran these groups are made up of huge
aircraft barriers accompanied by Supply
and warships we're talking 15,000
Sailors in total standing watch as this
conflict escalates the US also readies
its missile defense systems and prepares
soldiers for deployment it's a huge show
of force and it's the us trying to use
its Superior military power to send a
signal to Iran and its proxies that they
are there and they are watching and that
they will be dragged in to any
escalating conflict to any country any
organization anyone thinking of taking
advantage of this
situation I have one word
don't don't and then against the warning
of the United States Israel sends troops
into Gaza Israeli troops and tanks
Advanced further into Gaza engaged an
urban combat the ground invasion is more
limited than expected but it's what the
Israeli Prime Minister is calling the
second stage in their plan to completely
destroy Hamas and its
leadership as Israeli troops flooded
into Gaza the big question was would
Hezbollah act would they invade from the
north and surprisingly they didn't and
this shows us three things that weren't
as clear before number one it shows that
the price of a war for Lebanon is huge
and that Hezbollah is taking that into
account they stand accountable to the
Lebanese people and Lebanon does not
want war it also shows us that Iran is
hesitant to use Hezbollah in this
context Hezbollah is their most powerful
card to play in deterring is Israel from
ever attacking them and in using it to
protect Palestinians they will weaken
hezbollah's role as a deterrent or to
say it bluntly what this shows us is
Iran cares much more about its own
security than it does about the plight
of the
Palestinians but the third thing that
this shows is that Hezbollah believes
that Israel will not be successful in
their mission to eradicate Hamas
according to a Lebanese Diplomat who
talked to the New York Times Hezbollah
has been quote quietly telling its
partners that it believes that Hamas is
in a good position and does not yet need
hezbollah's help and indeed Hamas itself
has come out and said that they are
ready that they've been preparing for a
ground Invasion because they have an
advantage inevitably this ground
Invasion will mean luring Israeli
soldiers into a Labyrinth of densely
populated cities where Fighters can
easily hide and blend in with civilians
not to mention hamas's huge network of
hundreds of kilometers of underground
tunnels where they can hide store
supplies and store their hostages the
tunnels also have a psychological use an
unseen unpredictable angle designed to
keep enemies wondering when and where
they'll be ambushed for any Israeli
ground offensive this may prove the
biggest challenge it's a truly
excruciating kind of warfare in every
conceivable sense this is a quickly
changing situation and I don't know what
the conflict looks like when you are
watching this but right now the
bombardment of Gaza continues the death
toll of Palestinians is skyrocketing the
people are running out of food and water
and medical supplies the UN is
condemning Israel's response saying that
there's no justification for what Hamas
did but Israel's response is too much
too many civilians are being killed some
at the UN are even calling Israel's
actions potential war crimes and the
world is calling for a pause in the
fighting a ceasefire that would allow
humanitarian Aid to get into the strip
but a ceasefire is something that
Israel's prime minister says is not on
the table after after the horrific
attacks of October 7th calls for a
ceasefire are calls for Israel to
surrender to Hamas to surrender to
terrorism to surrender to barbarism that
will not happen Egypt has just started
letting foreign Nationals and severely
wounded people in the Gaza Strip leave
and cross into their country but they
continue to deny entry to the vast
majority of Palestinians Who Remain
trapped inside of this small rectangle
but they are together with Qatar helping
mediate between the sides already
facilitating a deal that released four
hostages that Hamas had captured on
October 7th for now Iran's axis of
resistance stands deterred from
escalating this any further continuing
small attacks but calculating that a
wider spread conflict isn't worth it
especially as the US moves its troops
into position it is a delicate balance
one that could easily break or spiral
all it takes is one miscalculation one
attack that was meant to be a message
but actually kills dozens of people
people and elicits a stronger response
which in turn elicits a stronger
retaliation which could lead to an
escalation a spiral into a catastrophic
war in the Middle
East and in the middle of this all
people and families who wanted nothing
to do with any of this who don't care
about the geopolitical calculations and
the balance of power in the Middle East
millions of people confined to a war
zone not sure if the last thing they
will ever see is the next air strike
from Israeli Jets innocent civilian
hostages kept in underground tunnels not
sure if they'll ever see their families
again and the families who are mourning
the loss of their loved ones who were
taken by this senseless conflict and at
the root of it all the leaders in charge
of protecting their people but who have
instead chosen to pursue policies of
division occupation violence and hatred
the ingredients that produce to this
current
situation so for now we will watch as
the Middle East sinks towards deeper and
deeper conflict and we will hope that
level heads will prevail in the
decision-making and that somehow we can
prevent more suffering and more loss of
life this is gearing up to be months if
not years of conflict in this region and
I will be following it trying to make
sense of it for everyone if you want a
broader context of what the Gaza Strip
is and what the Israeli Palestinian
conflict is all about which I did not
cover in this piece there is a great
series called modern conflicts by real
life lore where he goes into the roots
and the context of this conflict it's
very very important to understand if you
want to try to make sense of what's
going on here the modern conflict series
is available exclusively on nebula which
is a streaming platform that is run by
all of us creators I put all my videos
up there early and AD free and there's a
bunch of exclusive content including the
modern conflicts series by real life
lore but there's tons of other coverage
of Israel and Palestine and it's a great
way to learn not just about this
conflict but many other conflicts and
topics and histories I mean on nebula
there is a huge diversity of really
fantastic educational videos a lot of it
exclusive to nebula so you can't watch
it anywhere else last year like 10,000
of you signed up for this after I talked
about it uh using this like bundle deal
that gave you a big discount that deal
is expiring now because it's been a year
I just got the email saying that the
bundle is breaking you're not going to
be able to have access to nebula anymore
if you want to retain your access to
nebula to watch my videos early and
adree and all this other stuff there is
a link in my description it is
nebula.jpg five bucks a month if you do
the monthly thing a part of that
subscription goes directly back to us to
help fund our journalism to help us make
more videos like this so if you're
interested in watching a bunch of stuff
ad free on nebula and supporting this
channel make sure to use the link don't
just go to
and I'm just a believer in good
independent journalism and creators
banding together to build something like
this so I will see some of you over in
nebula and for the rest of you thank you
for watching subscribe to the channel if
you're not already and um we will see
you soon in a future video thanks
guys hey for those still watching don't
forget to check out our new channel
search party which is run by my old Vox
colleague Sam Ellis Sam's working on a
big video right now that's another angle
of the geopolitics of the Middle East
which will be publishing in a few weeks
so make sure to go over and subscribe to
not miss
[Music]
it